so you're voting for trump i am is there
anything particular that stands out
to you as like why you need to support
him
okay i didn't used to believe that you
should
your vote should be primarily a vote
against anyone
but that has changed for me recently um
uh the number one reason i'm voting for
him is he's the only candidate i see
right now who's not speaking
woke even joe jorgeson the libertarian
candidate oh man
i wanted to vote for her she's speaking
woke can you
i it sounds like you're parroting my
opinion he said the other thing last
night
yeah i was like i hate that you know i
never want to vote against anybody i
don't believe in that i believe in
standing up
but i i felt at first for a while i felt
really forced
like i'm i'm thinking about it i'm like
am i really gonna walk in there and vote
for trump
i have no choice like i see what they're
doing and this ideology is doing and
trump is resisting it
now with the afghanistan thing i got i
gotta be honest that was big for me i'm
like i'll take it you know what i mean
but joe jorgensen libertarian party
the premise of which is don't tread on
me quite literally said
we must be actively anti-racist and i
said no no we mustn't do anything
libertarian
you know i'm not trying to be mean i
think she didn't realize what she was
doing or saying
but she's just repeating it exactly and
that's even worse in my opinion
yeah because then you're doing it
mindlessly your and your you're
taking a knee to the ideology and just
basically saying i'm i will be beholden
to this belief system without even
realizing what it is like inviting a
vampire into your house
and when you look up the definition of
the ideology of anti-racism
like you said it's racism it's racism
it's like being constantly cognitive to
racial identity and racial structures
and i'm like judging
you know and it says judging people
based on this and i said no i i will not
not be having any of this i've i've
received tons of messages from people
who said they don't like trump and they
were going to vote libertarian
until she tweeted that until she did
that and now they realized
this infection this cult whatever is so
widespread even the libertarians are
embracing it
and it feels like hopefully there's a
silent majority
that this is it's all washing over the
silent majority and eventually they'll
all rise up and say
enough and vote for trump because he's
the one who's saying no to this
yeah i'll say hopefully so i can say
some things i like about him it's not
i just want to be honest that mostly i'm
voting against social justice ideology
and that's not a one-issue
vote by the way because your ideology
influences
every single policy decision you're
going to make um
but there are some things he's done that
i like i like the
the right to try absolutely all that we
talked about i like
prison reform i like he made the aids
drugs free
i like that he i mean he's done things
that people
on the left should be able to say you
know what i like that thing
even though i don't like him and they're
not able to do that why is that
ideology tribalism cultism didn't he
just reduce the price of epipens and
insulin
well it was an executive order so i
don't what a racist
right you know it's uh
it's it's a deceptive media and it
scares me when they try and compare him
to
hitler because he says fake news and i
worked in the news industry and they
told me to lie
well they well they i'll to clarify side
with the audience
yeah side with the audience what does
that mean
and i asked does that mean if there's a
factual news story that would offend the
audience we don't report it
yeah i think that's fair wow yep
so if there's a
think about that in practice there's a
fight proud boys antifa
if i say that antifa hit the proud boy
and started the fight
that would offend the audience we don't
report it wow so then what do we report
a fight broke out antifa got beat up so
it frames it by omitting that
information
that's what they told me to do i think
you know didn't you quit
well i kind of i tried okay and they i
was under contract
and so they ended up giving me a bonus
because i think what they're trying to
do is like
fall in line bunny in the fall in line
buddy the money is good
and i said dude i can make money i'm not
i'm not
that's not my mission you know my
mission is
better understanding of the world
helping people understand the world to
the best of my abilities
i would be happy sitting down by the
lake fishing all day and night i'm not
worried about your your golden you know
handcuffs
so when the contract was up i was gone i
said no thank you
yeah they tried though i'm not playing
ball and
some of the people who worked there
would call me a white supremacist behind
my back
and it was the craziest thing to have
white progressives
telling me this and i never even said
anything to them
it was just i wouldn't fall in line so
they they've absolutely altered the
definition of white supremacists while
they quite literally
are are i saw them called charles
barkley a white supremacist they'll call
anybody a white supremacist who doesn't
believe
again people have to get over their fear
of name
who cares what they call you you know
what you are yep like
well they're worried about getting fired
yeah cancel culture
i i want to say one thing i don't know
how long this lasts so i want to make
sure i say this
if you are afraid now of speaking and i
get it
all those fears are legitimate your job
people are afraid of losing their job
people afraid
of their family safety they're afraid of
losing friends like their social
standing
i get it but just imagine where we'll be
in 10 to 15 years if you don't speak now
if people don't start speaking now and
you don't have to get a podcast or
go you know wear a maga hat or you know
pick your battles you can just start by
having a
don't be afraid in a conversation with
friends or family to push back a little
bit
yeah i you you be polite yeah make sure
make sure you're not getting overly
angry
and yep i'm i'm i'm personally not
interested in emotional victories
you know what i really don't like is
there some people who will try and feign
a good conversation you're talking to
your family member
they start getting angry and they'll be
like you don't need to get angry at me
i'm
no none of that you say i'm sorry i'm
not trying to make you mad no seriously
like
you want to chill and we'll just come
back five minutes from now i'm not
you know please don't get mad i'm sorry
i got you angry i just want to talk to
you
yeah try and actually have these
conversations with people it's not easy
you have to be it's not easy it's like
going to the gym
and you have to do a practice a lot you
can't just go to the gym once and
some days you're going to not go to the
gym and you're going to suck at it and
you're not going to be
nice but then the next day try again and
i really try and remember that is like
okay i used to believe this stuff for 20
years so
whenever i get a little where i'm kind
of angry at these people or whatever in
a conversation and try and remember
what i've said to my younger self you
have to be that soft landing place for
when people wake up
what would you say to your younger self
or to an sjw
to like kind of open the door and have
you know kind of a wake up moment for
them
here's a question i haven't heard anyone
answer yet
i told lydia this today okay so one of
the things they try to do
is they they are really concerned with
redefining words
because as we've talked about um they
redefine anti-racism everything yeah so
they have to redefine words because
controlling thought is how they control
people so how do you get for example how
do you get people who are against racism
or sexism
to treat people differently on the basis
of race and sex well you tell them well
these
they're these new definitions for racism
and sexism now
and these new definitions say that
racism and sexism equal prejudice plus
power and that means that it's
impossible to be racist towards white
people it's impossible to be sexist
towards men
so they push this and they're teaching
kids this right so here's my question
and this is in good faith let's say i
accept your definition
and okay we're going to start teaching
that racism is prejudice plus power
and it's impossible to be racist towards
white men
at what measurable end goal will it
suddenly become possible to be racist
towards white men again how can we tell
and then practically how do you
roll put the genie back in the bottle
how do you roll this back now that
you've
taught generations of children that
racism is impossible against a specific
race
and the same thing for sexism how do you
measure when have we reached the
equality
point for you where we wake up one day
and we're like oh wow now it's possible
to be sexist towards men
okay now we've got to go teach the kids
something else
how do you do that they can never answer
that for me well you see what
you know in colleges men are the
marginalized community
because colleges are predominantly
female now there are more
women in college than men are there more
there are more women graduating
and so we've actually seen a wave of
lawsuits over the past couple of years
where they're still doing like women and
stem and things like this well
we there's still a disproportionate
amount of men relative to women but
there are there are programs like women
learn x and women do x and there have
been lawsuits saying if women are the
majority in these schools then how do
you justify a program that benefits
women it's benefiting the majority and
they've been winning and actually
dissolving
these groups i think ultimately where
this ends is no civil rights for anybody
because you you think about the logical
conclusion of anyone being any identity
they want
you know people who are you know i think
it was brown university says
if you're a person of color you just
identify as it and then you get the
privileges
afforded yeah so what's the end result
um men and women competing on the same
teams as they desire
uh which ultimately would result in
biological males just dominating
everybody no gendered sports
yeah no gendered sports and uh
you know no programs to benefit anybody
they lump every you know asian into one
group and ultimately it just results in
no civil rights for anybody but not in
not in the sense that it's like a
meritocracy anymore
right in the sense where it's like
everybody is equally being hurt i think
so too
well look at some of the results of
what's happened with things going too
far because
you have companies now where men are
saying they don't want to take meetings
alone with women
oh totally and that makes absolute sense
because now what culturally we've
arrived at a point where
uh i believe all women just nonsense
and and so why would you take that risk
and so women are hurting because we've
taken things so far
and i know some people are like they're
even hesitating to hire women now
because what happens if you fire them
and what could the woman say and now we
believe all women
what would happen if a male co-worker
walked in and i went damn jack
if you've been working out you're
looking great that's a new suit
stunning i'm impressed now imagine a
woman walking in
i'm saying the exact same thing ooh
janet wow you've been working out you
look great
timmy's great stunning dress i'm
impressed
so creepy it doesn't work you could walk
up to a guy and pat him on the shoulder
and grab his elbow and be like good job
you do that to a woman
you're in trouble yeah so so it's that
right there where you realize
men and women have different
expectations i can i
you know guys can give each maybe it's
inappropriate guys shouldn't be even
touching it all
fine i think you know the reason why i
say i think it ends up with everyone
being equally hurt
no rights for anybody is that to truly
get equality you must find the lowest
common denominator
so that means the lowest prim you know
marginalized person
everyone must be hindered to that degree
yes they want
us it's uh i'm sorry it's what's that
what's that short story harrison
bergeron
yes oh my gosh this woman is me i love
it so much
that story is you're right it's short
it's it's not
uh it's kurt vonnegut it's anybody can
read it in one sitting and
wow you're right lydia that's exactly
what we're living through exactly
they put so the the people who are
good-looking
have to wear bags over their heads so
that their everyone is equally
unattractive
the people who are smart have to have a
noisemaker in their ear
yeah to disrupt their thoughts the most
talented dancers have weights on their
arms
and this is a social justice utopia guys
we're all
equally awful at everything that's an
amazing story
because after one of the shows someone
sent it to me and it's like it ends with
this super
ripped chiseled seven foot dude just
like ripping everything off and dancing
with a beautiful woman or something
yeah that's perfect it's awesome yeah
but it's not going to be that
magical i guess the you know when it
comes crashing down
i fear that true liberalism
classical liberals and the idea of the
extent of the governed individual rights
and
you know and responsibilities was hard
earned you know we fought very very hard
for this over a long period of time and
and even when this country was founded
we didn't have it perfect
and it's taken a lot of you know
conversations over hundreds of years
to get to where we are now where people
are more likely to have
their rights granted and protected yeah
so they want to turn the clock back
they want to go back in time they want
to erase all that stuff it is not
liberalism
and so what i fear is going to happen
we've grown complacent
not us obviously we are sitting here
saying like yeah as a culture we've
grown
complacent it's that that's saying you
know uh hard times make strong men
strong men make good times good times
make weak men weak men make hard times
so maybe we're in for a hard times you
know coming forth i mean we're in hard
times look we got the pandemic we got
the economic crisis and whatever you
can't even travel outside of the country
for the most part so we're in hard times
now
i think we are maybe going to
enter some version of the dark ages but
with like really scary technology
and then after that though i do think
there's
a place for enlightenment again i think
there will be a
reaction i think that that reaction is
already starting you're starting to see
people speaking up against it and you're
starting to see
liberals finally getting the courage to
stand up and say
this is not liberalism i think if
the silent majority does exist and we
and and i think we believe it does
because we've gone over a bunch of the
data there was a cato institute poll 62
percent of people are scared to to speak
certain opinions yeah
the only faction is the far left where
their the majority feels comfortable
speaking their opinions
that says to me that i i believe the
silent majority is real i think the
democrats know they're going to lose
will see you know i'm i'm not a psychic
it's just what i'm looking at now
sure biden's up in the polls but now
trump has closed in battleground states
to a point to one point which is well
within the margin of error
yeah trump very well may actually get a
solid victory
i wouldn't be surprised if we saw a
major landslide however if that happens
i think we're in for really good times
you think so
well there's a possibility of war with
china you know to be completely fair
but you look at the economy under trump
for three years and the only bad times
we had was the media wouldn't
shut up and there was some rioting and
stuff but the economy was
was incredible the best numbers of our
lives says jim cramer
i talked to locals around my area and
they said they've never made more money
in their lives the best year ever
yeah and they were celebrating the covet
hit so i think if trump wins
the economy is going to reignite trump's
going to do what he did over the past
several years
the jobs are going to come back the
economy is going to erupt people are
going to be happy and it's going to be
gosh tim i hope you're right well i
really do
i i'm a little worried about how long
the media is going to play this
corona thing out in the same way that
you said the bringing russia gate back
i'm not saying the virus
the virus is real obviously but i think
the media manipulation
and the um media induced hysteria over
it yep
how long are they gonna use that as a
weapon there
there have been several threads popping
up and stories suggesting we may have
already
heard immunity a long time ago but
because of the way the narrative
works you're only allowed to say the end
is nigh
yeah so it actually you know might be
doing
we might be doing a lot better like
we've seen an increase in cases but a
decrease in hospitalizations and now the
cases are going back down again
which suggests you know at least some of
the threads i've seen from
various journalists hurt immunity i
think if trump wins
he's untethered you know he has to worry
he's as much as he could
now he's got a re-election to worry
about so he can do more
and there were some problems early on
with his administration i was not a fan
of he brought on john bolton and i you
know barfed in my mouth a little bit
yeah
and now he's doing a lot better he is
and considering the existential threat i
see from overt far left
white supremacy groups racial
collectivists
i'm like i'll take the the good economy
and the jobs
and the ending the war these things are
great you know
could we get a more professional ideal
of a president
probably but if it's trump i i've
decided we we need someone not woke to
win
yes and if trump wins then he's going to
be able to do whatever he wants
not worrying about reelection and that's
his true you know time to shine
the the the media lies about him being a
fascist have been completely disproven
he did not deploy the feds to various
cities and i'm talking about the law
enforcement not the investigators
and if he did maybe the riots wouldn't i
didn't know that yeah so there was a
media lie
trump deployed fbi atf and dea they're
helping doing desk work
but we saw that mass looting in chicago
that would have been stopped if trump
did deploy federal law enforcement
but he's not doing it because he's not
you know it really bothers me
when they say trump should have done
better on covet and i'm like he under
the 10th amendment he's the states are
responsible and he's not going to
intervene
well speaking of calling him hitler like
you said earlier these are the people
who
had convinced me he was a demagogue and
an authoritarian
i cried the night he was elected i
really believed all that stuff
and then to watch them now saying like
during covet why aren't you acting more
like an authoritarian please be an
authoritarian
i know and again i think part of this is
that what you the idea you were hitting
upon about
this sort of projection about these
people with white supremacist beliefs
preaching social justice ideology
because it is another form of white
supremacy
it's it's weird it's a trojan horse it's
a trojan horse but it's it's so it's
also similar i remember when he was
being inaugurated
i saw that antifa and some other people
were they'd planned this whole disrupt
the inauguration thing j20 or something
they called it okay so i went to their
website at the time and i was looking at
it
and one of the things they said one of
their goals was that they said they
wanted to cause so much chaos and
and disruption that that he had to show
himself to be the authoritarian that he
really was
and be sworn in behind closed doors like
the dirty little authoritarian he is
it's like wait a minute
so you're forcing him to be sworn in
behind doesn't that mean you're on the
side of
dark you know authoritarianism they
don't get it they're pushing the very
thing they claim to be against
you know what i really can't stand is
that they do the memes and the political
compass
and they always put antifa in the bottom
left left libertarian
yeah no no no no no no no no no no
no antifa is not you know left
libertarian are hippies i always say
santa farm sharing the watermelon they
just grew it's it's hippie's smoking pot
being like
you want some of my watermelon bro yeah
for sure you know hey i put up a hammock
you can use it if you want
thanks it doesn't work at large scale it
works for a bunch of hippies sitting on
a farm
antifa are authoritarians they believe
in using violence against other people
to get what they want they're they're
enforcing their ideological authority
over you with threats of fear and
violence
yeah trump is not doing that and they
desperately want him to
they want him to be that now they're
complaining he's not you why didn't he
you know i was talking to a friend of
mine from you know back in chicago he's
like why didn't
why didn't trump fix covet and i said
well it's 10th amendment i mean
trump can handle the federal government
and he's done that he's banned travel
he's you know uh put out guidance
programs but the states are responsible
for what they do
that's why you've got sunbelt states
that have done great south dakota done
great democratic states have failed
and they're like no it's trump's
responsibility he's the one you want him
to overrule all the governors and just
take over
you know i'm in yeah it's a same old
story right yeah thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
we do the show
live monday through friday at 8pm if you
want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you